during your visit michel bachelet the
high commissioner for human rights met
with the bangladesh prime minister
sheikh hasina and government high
officials as well as civil society and
rights groups
the high commissioner made clear that
extrajudicial killings and forced
disappearances were huge obstacles in
the pursuit of justice
i raised my deep concern about this
serious allegation with government
ministers and highlighted the need for
an impartial independent and transparent
investigation into these allegations
accompanied by security sector reform
several international and local human
rights organizations have urged the u.n
high commissioner for human rights to
press the bangladesh government to
ensure full accountability for the human
rights abuses that still persist in the
country
bashley also raised her concern about
self-censorship in bangladesh media a
consequence of the digital security act
we have submitted our recommendations
for repeal and revision of certain
provisions of the act
with a view to ensuring their compliance
with international human rights law and
standards and preventing arbitrary
application or misuse
bashley also visited the world's largest
refugee camp in cox's bazar on the
southeast coast
the international community must sustain
its efforts to bangladesh in its
response and press myanmar to create
conditions for return address the root
causes and pursue accountability
she met with several refugees in the
camp
i told her we do want to return to
myanmar but we don't want to face
repression and persecution again and
that needs to be ensured
she assured us that our demands will be
presented accordingly
not only i'm visiting here michelle
bachelor said the importance of
bangladesh's humanitarian contribution
and its historical significance cannot
be overstated
unfortunately the current situation
across the border means that the
conditions are not right for returns
representation must always be conducted
in a voluntary and dignified manner only
when safe and sustainable conditions
exist in myanmar finally she asked her
bangladeshi host to include members of
the rohingya community in the country's
social and economic sectors while they
were in exile tanvid choudhary
al-jazeera dhaka